so people are always looking for water
in space on other worlds on other worlds
orbiting other stars
there's a whole class of scientist or
discipline now called astrobiology life
of other stars life around other stars
we figure there are so many physical
objects in our world
whether you're a bumblebee or a petunia
or what else could you be an ancient
dinosaur butter on toast or you are made
of stuff and you walk around and you do
things or you grow toward the light or
you'd metabolize the seawater you live
and you're some living thing so there's
always a solvent as we say in chemistry
there's always some liquid that
dissolves these things the chemicals and
you can move them around redistribute to
make use of the chemicals and then the
solvent is largely unchanged so
astrobiologists have sought solvents and
right now water is the best one anyone
can think of now we haven't thought of
the other solvent on another world that
drives life elsewhere that is so far our
problem but the other big candidate for
you fans is liquid ammonia
well liquid ammonia okay we haven't
found anything on the earth or near the
earth that seems to live on liquid
ammonia but right now it's water water
seems to be the stuff so we are creating
telescopes and systems software behind
telescopes that will allow us to detect
water on another world and you would say
that how can you possibly do that dozens
hundreds of light-years away you're
crazy you're squandering our tax dollars
this is madness oh no my friends when
light passes through or reflects off of
water it has a characteristic signature
there are spectral lines there are
constructive and destructive
interference patterns in light
associated with
that would allow us to determine whether
or not their water and the other big
thing is is to look for the surface
temperature of the distant planet if the
surface temperatures 50 80 a hundred
degrees Fahrenheit then you're probably
on to something if you're at millions of
degrees Fahrenheit probably no liquid
water and so on